Elizabeth Smart is opening up for the
very first time in an interview about
why she believes one of her kidnappers
who is set to be released is still a
danger smart was rescued back in 2003
after being abducted and held in
captivity for nine months
Wanda bars Ian Bryan David Mitchell were
convicted for their roles in that
kidnapping the 72 year old bar Z will
walk free tomorrow after Utah fischels
determined they miscalculated her prison
sentence in an interview that you'll see
only on CBS this morning
smart explains why she thinks bars he
should not be released the now 30 year
old Elizabeth Smart also makes some
startling claims about what bars he has
been doing in prison assertions at CBS
News has been unable to confirm do you
feel stress knowing that that she's
about to be released it's been a roller
coaster it's been a roller coaster of
emotion of of worry of wondering what's
going to happen but I think at the end
of it what I just come to is that I
really have spent the last 15 years of
my life
trying to move forward and trying to
follow my mom's advice that she gave me
the day after I was rescued and what was
that and not allowing these people to
steal any more of my life away from me
but am i concerned yeah I am very
concerned for the community for the
public as much as I am for myself in the
beginning did you think that she would
help you did you ever think well at
least there's and there is a woman here
did you feel safety on some level with
her ever when he kidnapped me and was
taking me up into the mountains I
remember thinking this is it he's just
gonna rape and kill me and then at one
point he did end up telling me that he
had a wife that was waiting that moment
did give me a little bit of comfort but
as soon as I saw her I did not have that
hope anymore why I don't know just the
feeling that kind of radiated from her
it just was dark and it was evil
and I just knew that she she wasn't
there to help me that she wasn't there
to protect me you've written about this
and talked about it that you were raped
really that very first night and then
several times after that did you even
know what was happening to you at 14
years old did you even know what that
was that first morning when he brought
me into the camp and told me I was now
his wife and kept telling me it was time
to consummate our marriage I just at
first I didn't know what he meant
yeah and then I remember having this
idea come to my mind of what he could
mean
and I remember think there's no way and
I was raped and I was raped every day
after that multiple times a day and
every day multiple times a day every
time I think about that I I can't it's a
miracle you didn't have a baby I was a
little girl I had not hit puberty yet
when you say you think that she's a
danger what do you mean by that
dangerous how well I know what she was
capable of before she was incarcerated
so what do you think she would do I
don't know and perhaps that's what
worries me
because I know just how bad she really
can be she would encourage him to rape
me she would sit right next to me like
the side of her body would be touching
me like while he's raping you while he
was raping me I mean she was right there
so I mean she there were no secrets she
knew what was going on and I mean she
just was the kind of woman that she was
just evil and twisted and I remember I
remember when they used to force me to
to drink alcohol and one time they had
me drink so much I was 14 year-old girl
I never touched alcohol in my life that
I ended up throwing up and then passing
out in it and both of them just let me
lie there all night and when I woke up
the next morning I mean my face and my
hair were completely crusted to the
ground and they both laughed she laughed
she laughed just as much as he did if
not more we haven't heard anything about
the conditions of her release of you I I
don't know all the conditions of her
release but I have been reassured
multiple times that she will be kept a
very close eye on and as soon as she
masses up which I've been reassured that
she will she will be taken back to
federal prison for the duration of the
five years you said you've been
reassured that people are going to be on
top of her are you comfortable with that
I have been informed on who the agent is
who the federal agent is who will be
supervising her and I do believe that he
will do the job to the best of his
ability so I I have faith in him
I just lack faith in her in our next
hour she's gonna talk about why she
decided to speak out about her abduction
and what she's grateful for me and my
heart goes out to her because think
about this guy she's 14 she'd never even
kissed a boy before so your first sexual
experiences with someone who's so creepy
and so disgusting and you have a woman
there who does nothing to help you I
mean and and you look at her and she's
so darn normal if I can use that word
when you speak with her amazing
resilience and to be talked to be able
to talk about it so clearly and directly
and so powerful well you know she says
to me be honest and I've had 15 years to
deal with this and there's a thing it's
a funny thing if you're too angry people
don't pay attention to you you know
you're sort of dismissive if you're too
sad and you you can't tell the story
then it makes people uncomfortable to
hear it so she has figured out a way to
share the story of course she's angry of
course she's very afraid and she's very
worried but she has decided she's not
gonna live her life in fear anymore and
why is why is Wanda being released after
15 years well because that was a
sentence you know she had pleaded she
had pleaded to the crime that was a
sentence and you know they say listen
she has served the sentence it's now
time for her to get out and that's how
the Justice Department that's how the
justice system works Elizabeth has some
feelings about how the justice system
works too and we'll talk about that
still be a danger but she is she has
definitely served her time no question
about that
and think about this she is a mother
guys of
children Wanda Wanda is a mother of six
children Elizabeth said she doesn't
really even deserve the title of mother
she made giving birth to these kids but
she is certainly not a mother but she's
very articulate very composed really
really remarkable thank you is a really
compelling interview and I think
important to hear from her I do too
really important you have me too